I want to follow up on my coverage from
earlier this week about conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones and um what has
taken place over the last four or five
days with Alex Jones is really
remarkable and it it informs a number of
different uh uh uh aspects of these
coalitions that have been built over the
last four years and their fragility
quite frankly conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones was a big Trump supporter for a
long time he's also a big anti-vax guy
spreading unhinged debunked vaccine
propaganda regularly for the last year
year and a half Donald Trump recently
made two very mild pro-vaccine comments
while he said I still oppose mandates
and free we everybody has to have
freedom Donald Trump did say on stage
with Bill O'Reilly I got the booster
the vaccines are good and the vaccines
work and then Donald Trump said to
Candace Owens during an interview the
people dying overwhelmingly are the
unvaccinated and the right the anti-vaxx
right has gone crazy some of them now
see Trump as a traitor one of those
people is conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
so we're going to look at a couple of
clips and pay attention to the degree of
fragility for these coalitions that
immediately is made evident by Trump
saying something so mild and milk toast
about vaccines here's the first clip
this one's from the weekend we already
played this one earlier in the week but
just just for context is an emergency
Christmas Day Warning to president Trump
you were either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped Ram through with
operation warp speed or you're one of
the most evil men who has ever lived to
push this toxic poison on the public and
to attack your constituents now just to
be I I've been told it's really
important that I that I do this so that
the our content doesn't get blocked the
vaccines are not Gene therapies and they
are not poison
simply try to save their lives and the
lives of others we're about to lay out
the basic incontrovertible facts that
what you told Candace Owens just a few
days ago is nothing but a raft of dirty
lies that is untrue what Donald Trump
said to Candace Owens actually is true
but let's look at some other examples of
this here is Alex Jones losing his mind
on Donald Trump
for what he calls a satanic alien attack
a satanic alien attack
children with deadly poison everywhere
that they know erases their immune
system and Trump is running around in a
stupid red tie playing the part of The
Apprentice CEO it is important to know
that the vaccine does not erase your
immune system telling everybody oh
you're playing into their hands not
taking their shot no Trump you are
playing into their hands and destroying
yourself and signing yourself onto the
New World Order
the vaccines are not part of a new world
order conspiracy idiot Bill O'Reilly
what a pervert because you know how to
pick women up it's just Bill O'Reilly
may be a pervert that that actually may
be accurate it's all just an incredible
joke
see
I I just can't get mad on there anymore
you know there's a Gregory's report
There's A Gregory's report they just
followed it's so important
and so let's just air that
and I may just go to rebroadcast I'm not
trying to be dramatic here I just
I may just never come back you know I
mean seriously just let everybody have
what you want let's chip and Pelosi rob
you let them molest your children let
them take your four-year-olds away there
is no evidence that Nancy Pelosi or Adam
Schiff have ever or planned to molest
any children their genitals off you love
it everybody's too busy with their own
life and their own thing and they're on
this and they're on candy ass BS to wake
up out of the coma that there is a
satanic off-world alien attack going on
on this planet the vaccines are not a
satanic off-world alien attack okay so
understand how fragile these alliances
are these people have principles that
they abandon as soon as reality
conflicts with the principles these
people form coalitions that are so
fragile that as soon as there is any
difference of opinion you have Alex
Jones seemingly having a psychotic break
look at this next clip I mean look at
what is taking place here because Trump
said hey the vaccines are pretty good at
protecting people from dying persecuted
for supporting trump it makes actually
10 times worse because I know podesta's
evil I know Hillary's evil I know
Obama's evil and I know fauci's evil and
I know Bill Gates is evil and I know
they're all
they're all but Trump didn't
and so the fact that he's done this
makes it personal it makes it hurt
persecuted for supporting Trump so look
at the look at the triggering
Alex Jones who as he says was a major
Trump supporter cannot handle cannot
handle Trump's mild support for vaccines
let's look at just a couple more of
these all right take credit for it's a
great what we've done is
sign on to it take credit for it take
his shine on believe it I mean hell
we're fighting Bill Gates and fauci and
Biden in the New World Order and Saki
and and and and and the Davos group and
and Peter dazick and now we got Trump on
their team so Trump now officially
persona non grata according to Alex
Jones here's just one last thing there's
this uh sort of pseudo this is pro-trump
activist uh Allison Steinberg who was
invited also onto Infowars she also now
has turned on Trump check this out a lot
[Music]
if you go to this hotel in New York you
have to show proof of papers now of
course remember proof of papers by the
way proof of vaccination
what understand that nobody's forcing
you to go to Trump's hotel you have
total choice there's no obligation to go
to Trump's hotel
please Trump do some great things while
in office absolutely was I a supporter I
was a huge one
but there's no denying that what he is
doing is evil so there it is just
incredibly fragile alliances in the
world of trumpism and
um the the the reality that we have to
understand is that these people uh when
you don't really have principles to
begin with and that's one of the
Hallmarks of the trumpist movement which
is
part of why he won is he activated
people who had no idea about the
political world history what how
politics Works their first involvement
in politics was oh I kind of like the
stuff Trump said I'm going to vote for
and so when you don't really bring any
principles in by which you evaluate the
man that you end up idolizing almost
like a deity
um you don't even really
have a political ideology against which
to evaluate their future actions and
that's why you're seeing these very
people immediately turn on Donald Trump
it's fascinating to see and Alex Jones
really really seems to be struggling
there we're going to take a quick break
and be back right after this
one of our sponsors is self-decode
self-decode is a genetic testing and
Analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your DNA this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about what
of substantive value can we get from
these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific DNA as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a DNA kit to get my saliva I did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks I had my results I found for
example that genetically I'm not at big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma unfortunately
I'm at slightly increased risk of
headaches which is true which is true
and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation
Etc very very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to ten years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code Pacman